i mean it's okay to change their mind
because it's a novel virus and
and you learn new things what was
outrageous about it was
to treat the scientific inquiry as this
monolithic thing that's written in stone
and so if you go if you run afoul of it
then your voice needs to be censored
because frankly you don't
you're not following the science dave um
that's the attitude
and and also the fact that questions
that were ultimately
philosophical questions or policy
questions okay
we have this virus what degree of
restrictions is appropriate
are there other goods besides just
preserving life against the novel
coronavirus that we should preserve
those aren't scientific questions and
yet a kind of expert class
by trying to shoehorn it all into
they basically uh tried to
push their policy preferences and their
philosophical assumptions
as scientific claims which of course
they're not you know a
a statesman or a state's woman dealing
with something like the virus
has to weigh various things not just one
virus but also
other sources of threat to human life
like loneliness and depression
and and joblessness
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the op-ed editor
of the new york post and the author of
the unbroken
thread discovering the wisdom of
tradition in an age of chaos
saurabh amari welcome to the reuben
report
thank you dave thanks for having me i am
really glad to have you
and i read the book this weekend and i
really thought it was fascinating
because in
in many ways we come sort of from
different worlds sort of from a
different school of thought
but i think that the conclusions that
you came to in this book are very
similar to the conclusions
that i came to in my book that i think
ben shapiro has come around to you
actually reference him at the top of the
book
that jordan peterson has come to and uh
i mean i'm looking forward to chatting
with you but before we do anything i
know you wanted to address
the room that you're in right now you're
not being held hostage are you
yes not being held hostage not being
interrogated by some eastern european
police state it's just that i my my own
apartment
is um filled with rambunctious kids
so therefore a neighbor of mine is who
doesn't live in his own apartment really
so it's a kind of dilapidated place
is kind enough to let me use his place
hence the weird wire in the back
it's the best we can do under under
covered circumstances so bear with me
that is the story and you're sticking to
it and you are doing this
from new york city so you're in crazy
new york i'm in crazy la
how's life in new york right now i think
it's getting a little bit livelier
um the masked insanity is
you could see people not wearing mass
outside anymore which is a relief
um but you know as you know in terms of
crime
and uh disorder it's just growing yeah
so before we get into the specifics of
the book i'm curious what what really
made you
write the book and and really focus on
these 12
questions that we're going to we're
going to go through each one and discuss
each one
but what really brought you to this
conclusion that this book had to be
written now i mentioned to you right
before we started
that the subtitle in an age of chaos
that was about to be
in the subtitle of my next book and then
your book literally came across my desk
and we
changed it all together but but we are
in a time of chaos
yeah so in my case it's a book i wrote
for my son max he's now four years old
when i started writing it he was two
um and i'm really worried about the kind
of man that our
contemporary cultural political
arrangements will
chisel out of him he's named after a
great catholic saint who
is saint maximilian kolbe who is
was canonized and is famous for having
um chosen to die
in place of someone else at auschwitz
and
to me that uh his coal-based sacrifice
exemplified an account of freedom it's
really an
older account of freedom which defines
freedom as being willing to
limit yourself even unto death that
accepting limits accepting sacrifice
accepting duty and my fear is that my
max
if just left to our own culture will
inherit a very different account of
freedom
one that defines being free is just kind
of keeping your options open and
getting ahead in life in very
materialistic terms
and so my the book is my attempt to
tether my son
and hopefully maybe the reader to that
older
uh for lack of a better world trade word
traditional account of freedom
and the best way i can do that i'm not a
i'm not a philosopher a theologian i'm a
journalist and a storyteller
is to try to poke holes in some of our
contemporary certainties
and so i do that by posing 12 questions
that are either unasked or
that our age assumes have been
supplanted or made unnecessary that
science has basically
pushed them aside or what have you when
in fact they're still pertinent to what
it means to be
fully free fully human and then i
explore each of them through the life of
a
one great thinker um some of them kind
of
predictable maybe c.s lewis saint
augustine
but others will surprise readers because
you know they're
they're um not figures you typically
associate with the term
tradition and it's a kind of you know
it's a genre that i
invented in the sense that i pose these
questions and then i explore each um
through the narrative and the drama of
one life story
so the reader when he he or she reads it
will just um
will not be hit thick with philosophy
you're drawn into a story
and that's what propels each chapter
yeah and you end it really
on a nice note with a very short note to
your son
and what you hope the book has done so
let's talk about those
those 12 questions and you laid the book
out in two parts so part one which is
the first six questions
is the things of god part two is the
things of humankind so the first
question
is how do you justify your life and it
does seem to me right now
there is a huge amount of people
especially young people
that can't justify their lives so
they're acting out in all sorts of crazy
ways
right at their most most extreme they
say that if life is not worth passing on
in one way or another
um aoc um said some something
like that with respect to climate change
you know why would you put a child into
the world
um and that question really is a
critique
of of scientism not of science
which is a perfectly noble endeavor
that's unlocked lots of useful things
and
and helped unlock the mysteries of
really the cosmos and nature
but the attitude that would apply um
scientific the scientific outlook or the
scientific way of looking at the world
to the whole of life um and so
the reason i start with that question is
because i think a lot of
a lot of young people especially like
you said think
that because we know a lot about the big
bang
or cosmology uh
physic philosophy and and religion have
been
made superfluous you don't need
metaphysics anymore because
you know we have the big bang or we have
uh evolutionary theory
and uh you know what i argue and that
chapter is based on the life of c.s
lewis who was a great critic
of scientism in the 20th century is that
there are certain questions
uh about you know what's beauty or what
is beautiful why is something beautiful
why something ugly
what it means to be fully human what it
means to
to fall in love and so on and so forth
which don't have
they have right or wrong answers but
those right or wrong answers can't be
formulated using
facts which is the product of scientific
inquiry
and um so yeah i mean i i have to get
rid of scientism first if i'm writing
this book for my son
because he'll be bombarded with the idea
that uh you know
neil degrasse tyson has made aristotle
unnecessary yeah so of course you were
writing this during at least a portion
of the lockdown
and covid and everything else that's
going on and one of the things that
we've seen i think for the last year is
just the absolute
destruction of the elite class when it
comes to science
that people no longer trust the experts
because the experts
basically change their mind every week
for the last year and a half and that's
really no way to live
i mean it's okay to change their mind
because it's a novel virus and
and you learn new things what was
outrageous about it was
to treat the scientific inquiry as this
monolithic thing that's written in stone
and so if you go
if you run afoul of it then your voice
needs to be censored because frankly you
don't
you're not following the science dave um
that's the attitude
and and also the fact that questions
that were ultimately
philosophical questions or policy
questions okay
we have this virus what degree of
restrictions is appropriate
are there other goods besides just
preserving life against the novel
coronavirus that we should preserve
those aren't scientific questions and
yet a kind of expert class
by trying to shoehorn it all into
they basically uh tried to
push their policy preferences and their
philosophical assumptions
as scientific claims which of course
they're not you know uh
a statesman or a state's woman dealing
with something like the virus
has to weigh various things not just one
virus but also
other sources of threat to human life
like loneliness and depression and and
joblessness do you think we needed right
yeah yeah do you think we needed sort of
a philosopher class that could have been
working alongside the scientific class
to deal with this so we have a political
class
that works alongside of them but that we
really needed somebody else to discuss
those
issues i wouldn't put academic philos
i majored in philosophy and i obviously
i'm a a kind of
amateur lover of philosophy so as but i
wouldn't put philosophers in charge i
think ultimately it has to be
statesmen and states women and and uh
you know elected bodies because that's
how our government works
but it would it would have been nice to
have had
not just dr fauci but ethicists and
and bioethicists and and other people
who would who would
and and frankly uh you know pastors and
religious
figures because that's an important
dimension of human life if they were all
in form and then a statesman
chooses from among them rather than
elevating one
form of knowing one form of knowledge
which is perfectly legitimate in its own
realm
and making it into the sort of uh idol
where and if you cross it then you're
you're against science
so that's actually the perfect segue
then for for the second question which
is
is god reasonable and
as you may know i made a pro-god
argument in my last book as i was
defending liberalism
and what i found was this is where a lot
of liberals sort of get disjointed the
the bill maher liberals let's say sort
of get completely out of whack when you
say anything
about belief um so i'll let you answer
your own question there
well lots of um uh religious people also
get out of whack in response to that
which is that the liberals will say that
um
religion is only a matter of feelings
and therefore is sort of irrational
and some religious people go along with
that um
and they will say yes my faith is just
purely based on
on revelation and it it'll be
unreasonable and it makes me do
unreasonable things at its most extreme
do you have radical islam
of that kind of view that says well god
tells me to kill the infidel
and there's no arguing with that and so
the chapter
is an argument for you know basically
the the
classical proofs for god and for the the
the specifically the medieval mode of
reason which i argue was a more
capacious
and generous account of reason that said
that not only
can you reason about uh you know what
you could see through demonstrative
knowledge i
i i see certain changes in the seasons
or i
observe regular movements of the
heavenly bodies and that tells me
something
about them but also i can then reason
further beyond that
and not relying on revelation at all or
the bible or what have you just using my
natural reason
um i would have to find some way to
explain what
why all this change happens so what what
is the ultimate
cause behind all of these and that
as as saint thomas famously concludes
each of his five proofs for the
existence of god
that's what people call god you know
right and so
it's it's a it's a it's a case really
for what's called
natural theology you know what you can
learn about god
not using the bible
but just using your human reason and the
fact that
this god would allow you to know him by
your reason
suggests that he's also a reasonable god
so a god who doesn't call you to
kill the infidels what do you think
about the sort of micro
verse macro argument when it comes to
this that you know i know plenty of
non-believers and atheists that are
perfectly moral
people and decent upstanding citizens
but
at a macro level at a societal level it
just simply
cannot work you actually get into this a
little bit later in the book so we'll
get there too but
that it just it doesn't scale basically
yeah i mean i mean first of all there's
an argument from just looking at history
that
some of the worst regimes in the human
history have been
the atheistic ones because if you remove
some higher authority that that checks
human power
and say well man can do anything he he
wants
that's an invitation to stalinism that's
an invitation
has been an invitation to the horrors of
north korea and the chinese communist
party
or what have you um but more
fundamentally i mean
look the the people who are
making claims about what's good or
what's moral
um in a way in in st thomas's terms
they're already arguing for god
because if there is if there's something
that's that's good then there must be
something that is the most good
and the that thing that you must imagine
is the most good is
has you know what is what people call
god because there are
these degrees of perfection so um
i think that when people say that in a
way it's an invitation
to god rather than a refutation did you
happen to see the clip that went viral a
couple weeks ago of jordan peterson
talking about god and belief with tucker
carlson
did you see that by any chance it is
probably on that on that show that
tucker calls from tonight i i
love it but i haven't seen that episode
no there's a really extraordinary clip
i'll i'll gladly send it to you
where jordan's basically talking about
belief in god and he said that when he
when he was about 25 he decided
to tell the truth meaning for the
truth's sake that
no matter what the outcome of saying the
truth not that everything will be good
but it will be the best possible outcome
because you're putting order into the
world as opposed
to putting lies out there and he said
that that was the ultimate expression of
faith believing in truth
just for the purpose of truth and i
thought that was
as well explained as i had heard
basically
i agree i agree and um you know order is
the first law of the
of the cosmos and um you know my own
look i was an atheist i decided i was an
atheist when i was 13 years old
and um the way that i made my own way to
believe in first of all a god and then
ultimately
a personal god was because of
because of the conscience right like i
had this voice inside
me that directs me to try to do good and
avoid evil
and i had to and it seemed to hint that
there was an objective moral order and i
sensed when i was
at odds with that objective moral order
and
then i had to ask what is the source of
that moral order and ultimately
became that that's that there's a
there's a god who is the lord of that
order
um now scientists might say well that's
you know uh the voice of thousands of
years of evolutionary
uh uh kind of ingrained behavior sure
as a how answer or an answer to a how
question
or um it's your synapses firing your
brain
sure that's again a question an answer
to a how question
but it doesn't answer those why
questions which find the sort of
richest fullest answer in that in in god
right so that
basically that thing that sits behind us
all the time that sort of is your moral
compass that
that kind of led you there so that gets
us actually to question three quite
nicely why would
god want you to take a day off you mean
we're allowed to take days off still
i don't think many of us are and i'm i i
live as harry to life as anyone where
i'm
constantly you know right now i have my
phone on airplane mode and that's making
me twitch
what's happening um but the chapter is
really
a case for the sabbath um and then it's
told through the
point of view and life of rabbi abraham
joshua heschel
who was a great hasidic figure in the
mid-century and
he had obviously it escaped nazi germany
much of his family had perished in the
holocaust
and he comes to the united states and he
sees some of the same
restlessness that had disturbed him
about europe uh in the first half of the
20th century where
um as he saw it
much of life was devoted to making
conquest in what he called the realm of
space the realm of space is the realm of
geopolitical conquest it's the realm of
economic competition it's the realm of
doing better than your neighbor
and you know some of that is legitimate
those are important goods that you
should try to secure but he argued that
um that you also need to give some
do some time for the realm of well the
realm of time
which was the realm of the sabbath it's
the realm of the eternal where you
you actually declare peace on your
neighbor for a day you declare peace in
the economic competition
and you in doing that you find an inner
liberty because you're
you're setting aside all these kind of
material attachments that
define the rest of your life um and
i you know i argue in a in the chapter
that there's also kind of
setting aside all the religious
dimensions there's a kind of
temporal secular benefit through that in
the sense that
you know our lives we were told getting
rid of the sabbath
would be a source of liberation and in
practice what is
it is liberation it's liberation for the
market it's liberation for the
corporation
it's not necessarily liberation for the
family it's not liberation for the
worker
and um and i should mention this is a
theme throughout the book that's
something
that tradition proposes and looks like a
restriction on our freedom and you're
like oh i don't want this
in fact once you lose it you realize
that restriction
was a source of freedom and
paradoxically the loss of the
restriction
makes us less free you're more you're at
the mercy of your boss
well as you may know i try not to tweet
on the weekends and i usually tweet a
goodbye
on fridays and you know i'll be back on
monday and ben shapiro made the point
you'd know that
jews have basically been doing this for
a couple thousand years
yes it's been it's been around for a
while this
this relaxation do you find that
especially now
because of social media that this is of
particular importance to to take the
sabbath whether it
whether depending whether you're jewish
or christian or whatever whether it's
saturday or sunday or a whole weekend
do you think that the social media
component has really made this more
complex
well i mean i absolutely think i mean i
see again i see it in my own life i try
to take the sabbath
for christians the sunday sabotage i try
to take it seriously
um but there is that twitching like i
said and so there has to be
you have to impose discipline on your
your own life i mean
i favor certain restrictions like
limiting the as senator
hawley has proposed limiting the the
infinite squirrel or what have you but
at the end of the day look
you know you you've got to take
ownership of this and
and um there's so much to be gained from
turning everything off and not being a
slave to that ghostly blue glow
you know 24 7. again you're going to
join me for my august off the grid this
year what do you think
is that your okay i do it for lent yeah
but
i do it for all of all the end of my
book tour for this book as you
as you know it's a grueling uh so that
might be just the right time
i'll think about it i may have to
officially challenge you uh
question four uh i think this was
particularly poignant for my liberal
friends who are still struggling with
sort of shifting or seeing what i think
a new conservatism is
can you be spiritual without being
religious because a lot of liberals say
they're spiritual
but they're afraid of saying that
they're religious
and that's about 20 of americans now
identify as spiritual but
religious and what i argue in the
chapter is that the problem with that
isn't the religiosity it's the it's the
spirituality that
um a lot of these americans do all sorts
of religious things
they they do hot yoga they
drink only i don't know whatever hot
peppers and juice on fridays or what
have you
those have aspects of liturgical kind of
asceticism and
self-discipline in the body but they
don't have the shared
kind of public account of ultimate
meaning that religion brings together
religion
is a combination of those kinds of kind
of ritualistic actions
with some ultimate account of ultimate
meaning and
um when you have just the ritualistic
aspects
you're um you're doing it just for
yourself and it's kind of it's it's
private
and there are all sorts of things that
happen in traditional societies
that take religious rituals seriously
that you don't
access from that so i tell the chapter
through the life of
um victor and edith turner a pair of
british anthropologists
completely atheistic communist party
members
they go to africa as anthropologists to
study
tribal ritual and they noticed that
these tribal rituals as silly as they
may have seen to other anthropologists
actually have this important function in
society they um
they help solve resolve what would
otherwise been intractable conflicts
they
remind the powerful that they're
ultimate ultimately powerful only to
serve the lower
um and and and generally they kind of
provide for a a kind of humane
um society as a whole that's what ritual
did and they came ultimately when they
cam came back to britain
they were their assignments were done
they they became cast like themselves
because of what they had seen um but
i you know what what they would have
looked would if they had seen
our version of ritual they would have
noticed the
cave ritual but it doesn't it's a very
kind of merciless ritual so
for example we have a kind of
penitential right
right if you say something uh uh
inappropriate on twitter that's
considered offensive and it runs a foul
against pc rules you kind of do a kind
what looks like a confession
i confess to my friends that i have
greatly wronged through my fault through
my fault through my most greatest
you know agreement so we have that
it doesn't have the the other aspects
that make a penitential right like that
humane and and and full of mercy and
full of forgiveness
it only has the right and it's kind of
brutal
how damaging do you think it was that in
the last year and a half that people
were locked out of going to church and
and to
temple i mean the fact that they could
do some of the stuff privately obviously
but could
not have that public portion of this i
mean i tried it i i
personally tried going to internet mass
and it just isn't the same i mean
the mass especially has a kind of
embodied element as catholics believe
that
um uh you know the the lord makes
himself literally present
in the form of bread and wine uh the end
you know
virtually it doesn't quite work the same
um
and um no i mean i think it was a great
um failure on the part of
religious leaders across the nominations
and faith to be honest
but they so readily acquiesced um to
to these restrictions
and then and kept at it long after it
became clear that uh
you know that there are other risks to
be worried about
such as people falling away from faith
yeah although interestingly i think that
i'm sensing more and more people coming
back to faith now partly because of all
of this the the endless
chaos of all of this bless you the
endless chaos of all of this i think has
actually led
people back in a way i don't know that
it'll be exactly in the
in the way that you would want it to be
or that i would want it to be
but i do sense some sort of spiritual
awakening right now
is that true i mean i i haven't seen the
numbers i mean i i had to get
i don't know the number well if you look
at the numbers they'll always tell you
that there's more atheists now than ever
before
and really you know organized religion
is on the downfall but i do sense
something else because the the secular
world went so
out of control well there's nothing like
mortality to remind people of the last
things
and so i hope so yeah sure question five
does god respect you
i think this will uh this is a question
where
any number of people will uh object
if they think that look um my human
dignity is just founded in my
my being human my being my rights um
but i argue in the chapter that if you
don't think that the human being has
some special origin and some special
destiny
then why wouldn't you acquiesce to all
sorts of political horrors that
for example disfigure the 20th century
because human beings are just the
product of uh you know evolutionary
development
and and no different from other animals
or so you know why not have
um mass atrocities and so forth um
so i i argue that a lot of people today
who
clamor for uh social justice
uh reject religion out of hand because
they think it's just a source of
oppression but i argue that
the biblical faith because of the
emphasis and puts on on on the human
person as uniquely dignified as
as made in the image of god as genesis
tells us
it's a bold work against all sorts of uh
political injustices
and that i mean yeah i mean that's it
seems an obvious point to me but i know
lots of people disagree
yeah what about how religious or i guess
cult-like would be the better
explanation the the social justice
warriors have become
do you disconnect that from god or you
think these things are all tied together
well it just tells me that if if you if
you don't have
and this goes in maybe into the sixth
question but if you don't have god in
the public
square the the true god let's say
then you'll have other gods so that one
way or another our society will enshrine
some orthodoxy some god
some authority and the only question is
whether it's a it's a
merciful and and loving god or
a furious one like the god of ibrahim
kindy
right so that is really question six
which is does god need politics you
could have also said does does politics
need god right
yeah i mean i i god doesn't need
anything that theologians would tell us
and they're right because
you know he's a supreme being but um i i
argue that the god of the bible
um in entering human history
wants to transfigure not just our
private lives
but also our public lives so our cities
also want to
he wants to transfigure them and that
historically
societies have always had as i said
some uh some altar in the public square
and so the only question is which one
and in this is my kind of most
controversial
argument it's it's what makes me get
called the theocrat in
the new york times but
but it just seems obvious to me that
especially in the past two years or so
um when it's become so clear that the
loss of the
you know judeo-christian orthodoxy
whatever you want to call it
hasn't resulted in a neutral public
square it's
it's just empowered um kind of crazy
orthodoxies that
the demand that you um bow before them
right well that's why i thought this
chapter was so interesting because i
came at
all of this from a different political
perspective than you and yet i've come
to the same conclusion
which is that without god or some
organizing factor and we can
whittle that down how we may this is
what you get
the thing that we have right now where
we're debating biological differences
between men and women as if they don't
exist
that's what you get at the end right
right and so
i i just think there's no situation in
which you can say
well i believe that there are two sexes
a man and woman as genetics and and
genesis tell us and someone else thinks
there are 135
uh genders one of those were prevailed
and so um i think that
a lot of conservatives people on my side
of the divide really
but also some liberals too in fact a lot
of liberals
relinquish their responsibility to say
no no there is truth
about the about certain things we can be
absolutely certain about and
and and your interior
um misperception doesn't amount to truth
why do you think so many people folded
when it comes to issues like this
just folded so quickly let's say
yeah i mean i think there is a kind of
of of
abnormalism built into our philosophy
nominalism is this idea that that
um it's very old it come comes to us
from the medieval
age basically that certain theologians
said look
the world what we see is just the things
in it are too different to allow any
kind of essential classification
um now none of them would have gotten to
gender ideology i mean it would have
been
bonkers to them but you take that idea
far enough and you're like well
what does it really mean to be a man and
what does it really mean to be a moment
i know what i
am but i can't generalize about that to
everyone else
um so that that's the kind of
philosophical root of it and then
i think there's a a more basic level
um americans just just want to be nice
and so if someone
cries out and says well i'm conflicted
about who i am
i might be something other than what
nature or my body tells me
you want to respect that you kind of
want to you want to embrace them
but um sometimes that that
yearning to embrace and be nice can
actually be really
deadly and harmful uh part two
yeah i mean i know what you think the
origins are but that's what i see it the
other two a kind of philosophical
nominalism combined with america's
therapeutic culture like oh
but that person is hurting i want to
acknowledge i
i fully especially the latter part of
that i fully get that you know that's
where the liberal side of me i want
people
if someone feels that they are born
in the wrong body that doesn't change
the biology
to me but i want to have a society
that's as tolerant
and equal for someone uh like that as
possible
which i think in essence is the same
thing that you're arguing for here
i mean you want them to be treated with
dignity but what i've
found is that the demand for that
recognition
doesn't stop you're right it doesn't
stop that's the problem they'll say well
but then
you have to acknowledge that i'm i've
always been
caitlyn jenner and you're like well no
you you'll love this one to totalitarian
places but out of
out of basically good intentions i i was
once arguing with a friend although i'm
not sure he'd call me a friend anymore i
would call him a friend about about this
and he was sort of big on the
on the left side of this and all i kept
saying was
i want these people of course trans
people to be treated with dignity and
respect and i have sympathy for
the whole thing i said i said all that
i'm saying is that
can we just acknowledge that there are
biological differences between males and
females and he said this is exactly what
he said and this is where i knew the
conversation
was going to have to end pretty quickly
he goes dave you're not thinking about
quantum physics
and i said i you i said you're right but
either are you
like to me that was like the perfect
example of nobody knows what they're
talking about okay quantum physics
clearly
was the answer but speaking of quantum
physics part two is the things of
humankind
um question seven is how must you serve
your parents
i mean easy enough i i had to include
that in a book written for my son
um but um
this is the chapter you want to stick
obviously i think
um again to go back to the book's themes
is that
those um those restrictions that
tradition imposes that look like
uh impediments to freedom actually are a
source of freedom
filiality norms which uh obviously i use
confucius
because he's the ultimate thinker on
filiality but um you can also go to the
bible you know the commandment to honor
your mother and father
um are actually again another source of
humaneness and
what looks like why do i have to kind of
obey my parents
um you know confucius always suggested
that
you you especially in your most period
in your life your first three years you
you were unconditionally loved by your
parents and
that unconditional love taught you a
kind of moral imagination
which you can then see okay why would
anyone love anyone unconditionally i can
begin to love
other people beyond my own immediate kin
so um by honoring your mother and father
you begin to
build these circles of reality where you
it ripples out into a wider community
and you build a humane society
that was the basis of of confucian
philadelphia norms that they
cared for you and the difficult part of
it is that it's non-negotiable so
um both the mosaic law on filiality but
also the confucian version of it
they don't say well i have to honor my
mother and father if they were
if they met my expectations as a child
it's kind of absolute and um but i argue
that if you make a condition on whether
or not you
felt sufficiently loved or write love
the right way then the whole thing
collapses
um but um so how do you how do you
account for just people that are
terrible parents or a drug addicted
mother
or an abusive father or some of that
stuff like how do you
honor that properly and make sense so
you know certainly confucius didn't say
that you shouldn't correct an
aaron's parent so you should try to
correct an errant parent
and even if anyone is listening to this
and you ever like literally abuse a
parent you know you don't have to stay
with them you know
call the police whatever but there
should be some
element of of of love even
um even in those situations as an
element that this
that there is this mystery that i dave
rubin
literally the face of my the shape of my
face the shape of my nose
i got that from these two people there's
no other
you know and i wouldn't have gotten it
but for these two people and that that
imposes some obligation on us um
uh and luckily most people aren't in
situations like that most people
um don't have to deal with bad parents
but
the chapter will probably be painful
people who have legitimately abusive
parents
but i argue that the traditional norm
should be
upheld even at you as you make
exceptions for individual cases
because there's so much value in a
community in which
people kind of honor the
the hierarchy of of genealogy the
hierarchy of who
uh who brought you into the world i mean
literally you wouldn't be here
if it weren't for this union of these
two people so they
you have some there's something there
one way or another
there's some mystery that is very
difficult to just cast aside
and and shouldn't be cast aside so
chapter eight
i felt this was very important for me
should you think for yourself
now i have to do some same shameless
self-promotion here the subtitle
thinking for yourself in an age of
unreason
how did i do should you think for
yourself
um so i argue you should think for
yourself
in in important moral questions but that
in doing so
you shouldn't see authority as an true
authorities
as an enemy of your of yourself that
thinks
um a certain kind of liberal ideology
i mean i focus on the 19th century as
its origin always pits conscience and
authority against each other so i
i have my conscience and i and and for
me to fully exercise my conscience means
i shouldn't have to
listen to um various authorities i mean
the paradigmatic one would be the papacy
right in the 19th century there was this
question because the pope
had had been declared to be infallible
a lot of liberal reaction in 19th
century was well this means that
the individual conscience is at the
mercy of this external authority uh
in rome but the question i mean that's a
kind of catholic question but it extends
out to other realms of life as well and
other
groups and john henry newman who's the
sort of protagonist of that chapter
argued that the idea of the conscience
as this sacred inviolable thing
only works and only has power if you
think of the conscience as the voice
of that objective moral law that all
peoples recognize
whether or not they're even evangelized
or not even there's this kind of idea of
natural law that
is sprinkled across whether it's
confucian chinese civilization or muslim
civilization or judeo-christian
civilization
so there's this idea of natural law that
and you have this in
interior voice reflecting it and guiding
you to be
to be to bring your life into coherence
with this
this law if you think of the conscience
as a purely private thing well one
person thinks it's okay to
abort a baby at six months pregnancy
and another person thinks it's not okay
to do that and no one can be sure which
of the two consciences
is in the right you really undermine the
idea of conscience because then it has
no
is no it rests on no objective supports
and in that frame uh authority is really
not the enemy of the conscience it's
it's friend
the true authorities uh the bible the
papacy
um uh old proverbs
uh classical greco-roman tradition all
of these
are authoritative supports for your
conscience not your enemies of your
conscience so if you
constantly set them up at odds with each
other
you're gonna you're gonna get rid of all
the sort of authorities that
protected your conscience and then your
conscience is gonna be at the mercy of
corporations advertisers political
demagogues and so forth
but if you think of your conscience as
this special thing that needs
authoritative supports and you ring it
with those authoritative supports
then you don't you know the next
populist demagogue
or you know fake news meme or whatever
it is that you encounter
won't really sway you this way in that
so it's a different way of thinking
about conscience and authority
yeah do you think our our founders
really got it right when they set up our
founding documents because it seems like
they're
they're respecting both of these this
sort of empirical you know these are
god-given rights and also
we want you to live freely and live in a
way that makes sense to you
i'm so this is a complicated question
i'm more sympathetic to some of the
founders than others
uh you would probably guess this but i'm
a big fan of adams
who said that you know our constitution
is made for a moral and religious
book yeah i think you would agree with
this given where you're i haven't read
your new book but
given what you've said about it that the
rights that we
cherish need to have a moral substrate
and if you chip away at that moral
substrate
i worry that you just have kind of um an
insane rights culture and that's kind of
what we have
yeah that's sort of where we're at don't
worry the book the book's not out yet
but i'm gonna send it to you
uh chapter nine or question nine sorry
uh what is freedom for
so all the classical traditions define
freedom uh
in both again the greco-roman and the
judeo-christian tradition define freedom
as doing what you
ought to do um doing fulfilling your
duty
becoming who you are as a human being as
a rational animal a political animal
and not merely just having choice to
maximal
autonomy and maximum choice the chapters
focus on alexander solzhenitsyn who
famously disappointed a lot of western
audiences he escaped from the gulag he
had
written about the horrors of the soviet
regime when he came to the united states
and was asked to give a commencement
address at harvard in 1978
he focused most of his criticism most of
his polemical fire
at the west he felt that the obviously
communism was a horror and he knew that
and
he he denies denounced those horrors as
much as anyone
and and helped open the world's eyes to
it but he also saw a kind of diffused
tyranny in the west but it was
irony of a central government but the
tyranny of private actors each just kind
of pursuing a
a base account of freedom which i think
if you now move forward you know roughly
40 years
he was kind of right yeah i mean
especially i mean i think big tech
censorship to me is
just a really good example of this
there's this
um in our tradition a wonderful right
like
journalism holds power to account and
now you have big tech censoring you know
the newspaper i work for
new york post uh repeatedly last year
for stories where we
on both accounts we've been vindicated
both the wuhan labley theory and the
hunter biden story
and a certain kind of libertarian
autonomy maximizing person would say
well it's private actors doing it
who cares you know build your own
internet but a
humane person would say look if these
rights mean anything
then it's possible for a private actor
as much as the government
to violate them yeah i mean that's i
the founders could have never imagined a
powerful entity so
so much that it would dwarf the entire
government and here we are that's why
i've moved on this i don't make the
the per the purely libertarian argument
anymore
michael anton makes this point
beautifully in the june issue of first
things that they just didn't foresee
this degree of private power they just
couldn't have i mean i don't i don't
think there's any way that they could
have possibly imagined it
um question 10 i thought this was
interesting because now everything's
public all the time
is sex a private matter
yeah i mean look i think we live in a
as a sexually schizophrenic age uh
in the one hand uh you know we're told
to
pursue whatever we want sexually as long
as we seek our partner's consent and and
protect ourselves against disease and
that's the kind of sex is just private
fun
on the other hand we live in the age of
me too where it seems like that sexual
liberationism
in some cases has empowered some truly
horrible men and the the focal point of
the chapter is someone who
a lot of people will be surprised is in
a book written by a conservative but
it's andrea dorkin who was a
radical feminist really 70s 80s and 90s
um and she was a critic of the sexual
revolution i mean she came at it from
the left
and she just saw that you know the
sexual
liberationism has had in many ways led
to especially degradation for women
and um i argue
that in some sense she was a
traditionalist even though she would
hate to be in this book
if we're still alive she would not want
to be in a book next to augustine and
saint thomas right now she definitely
sounds like a traditionalist but then
not so much no no no but i argue that so
look the
the traditionalism of the 80s where it
was like all these feminists
talking about you were celebrating a
sexual ethic that was only
20 years old it was
it was boorish and horrible um
and and there's nothing kind of
christian about it and there's nothing
has it's it's only of like relatively
recent advantage
um and so the problem with with dorkan
was that she
accepted uh this diagnosis
of what had gone right wrong or she
proposed this diagnosis of what had gone
wrong with human with sexuality in the
west
and what was wrong with sex
liberationism but because she was such a
hard leftist
she couldn't look at the um the older
tradition of sexual restraint
because that was just the right and it
was bad
yeah i get this from a lot of my liberal
friends they get to the end of the road
and then the end of the road goes oh you
know
some of the conservative stuff was right
and that's where they suddenly get very
quiet you know
exactly yeah they don't want to make
that final
uh oh maybe i really was wronger about
some bigger stuff
that was her precise i already i mean i
the all the chapters
you know are fairly uncritical of the
figure profile
the dorican chapter i'm pretty critical
of her and where i'm critical is that
she
she didn't see the shortcomings of her
own worldview ultimately and
stopped short of going all the way to
look well maybe sexual restraint was
right do you sense that that
right there that inability to get that
last step that that's more of a
condition
of a of a liberal mind something like
that
well i mean i want to be fair i think
it's a it's a shortcoming for
all of us where where your worldview
takes you
you may stop short of going all the way
because it's uncomfortable
yeah yeah it's worthwhile to try to
avoid that yeah
exactly question 11 what do you owe
your body which i thought was really
interesting because we talk a lot about
you know your body your choice and now
it's uh everybody's got to get
jabbed and everybody's body is everybody
or we're going to kill grandma et cetera
i mean the chapter is really a critique
of modern gnosticism
in the ancient world in two three
hundred years after
the advent of christianity a whole bunch
of religions popped up
that were unique in the sense that they
said that the human person
is not the bodily you are this kind of
immaterial spirit that happens to be
trapped
in this fleshly apparatus and you can do
whatever you want with it um
you don't have it there's the body
itself doesn't have a norm
you are um what you should try to do
is to liberate this divine spark that's
trapped within you
and that might sound familiar to some
moderns because many
modern movements have the same tendency
transgenderism which we've already
talked about
is premised on the idea that um there's
this dramatic rupture between
who we feel we are interiorly and the
bodies that we receive from nature which
are sexed and you're either male or
female um
transhumanism is another example of this
you know this movement says think look
the human being
is just the mind and so if i can
download the mind
into some kind of software form and
untethered what it means to be human
from this again this body that's
prone to decrepitude and disease and
ultimately death
then that's liberation but um
the problem with all these kind of
movements is that they're an invitation
to
not only unreality because our bodies
are just
so ultimately a part of us but also an
invitation to
irresponsibility if i'm if i'm not
if i me i'm not the person
including this body then i don't have
all these inherited obligations
to family to the people who bore me and
gave me the shape of my body
to my larger community because i'm the
sort of spirit creature
and i can go you know i can use bitcoin
i can use virtual reality
and i don't need physical contact i
don't need to shake anyone's hand
and actually i think the lockdown is a
kind of have a gnostic tendency by the
way
you know people just say well just uh
the universities should just be an
online phenomenon
we should always wear masks because you
know what we don't need to see their
faces and even if we've conquered covid
uh there are other
uh there's the flu we could always
conquer the flu too and that
i mean all these tendencies i argue
trace back to this ancient heresy uh of
gnosticism yeah well they're they're
deeply
human needs you know a couple times
during the lockdowns i've done meet and
greets here in l.a which
i don't now i guess they're semi-legal
i'm not sure but when i've met people
people literally crying because they
haven't seen humans for that long
they haven't seen someone just stand
there and smile and and have a beer
and it's like that's that's deep we need
that it's so sad
i mean yeah it's human yeah but it's but
it's true
yeah the final question this is the
final question i suppose
what's good about death
i i look i i wrote that chapter at the
height of
the pandemic and um
it's it's focused on seneca the great
roman stoic
philosopher statesman who argued that
you know life becomes kind of
meaningless if you live forever
and that um it's not that he was said to
be a full hearty jackass and like jump
down 10 floors and and expect to live
but to that to live
in always in fear of of death
um prevents you from having the right
perspective on your life
you you hoard your possessions you
are fearful of new experiences you
there's all sorts of things that you do
if you sort of are just absolutely
fearful of death
whereas if you keep it in a rational
perspective and see look i'm going to
die
it actually liberates you to act you
know
boldly in life and as he did in his in
his life
but ultimately also that a life in which
you
don't have an endpoint is kind of
meandering it's like a novel that
doesn't have a beginning middle and an
end and those kinds of novels or movies
are terrible
um all the things we value in life
heroism
sacrifice true beauty they all find
their meaning in relation to an end
point if if you can live forever
they so they're all kind of cheapened
and now obviously
a christian or a faithful jew or muslim
wouldn't agree with him because he would
say there's an eternal life
but they would agree with him insofar as
saying with seneca that is that
that this version of of life of trying
to biotechnologically enhance life
forever
that's not eternal life that's a kind of
fake substitute
and i think that chapter resonates with
a lot of people because of uh
frankly the covet restrictions again
yeah it must have been fascinating just
writing that in the midst of covid where
it went from you know two weeks to
flatten the curve to now we're locking
down for a year
to then rolling lockdowns and then
suddenly it's like oh we can't open up
until there's zero chance for anybody to
get it which is actually statistically
impossible
and double masking which is my least
favorite site
i double let me ask you one other thing
that's not
in this you did not pose the question
but are you
are you hopeful that seems to be coming
up a lot with a lot of my guests i'm
trying to figure out who's hopeful for
the future
and why are you hopeful that we can turn
this thing around because a lot of the
questions that you pose here
are not things that we're grappling with
in a public sense in any real way i mean
obviously certain people are the book's
doing well and we talk about these
things here
but at a public sense when you listen to
our politicians and everything else and
just sort of the trends of the world
are you hopeful that we can fix this
i'm theologically hopeful in the sense
that hope is a theological virtue and i
think
um you know god's in charge so you know
in the very long term
everything's going to be okay um
in the short term
no i mean the leadership class in this
country is such i mean
i mean biden his senility his senescence
is so
kind of emblematic of this but so no i
mean in the immediate sense
but i do think the the depths that we're
in and you have an audience of people
who
you talk to i have an audience you sense
that everyone thinks there's something
wrong
something's gone wrong with the west we
can't quite
uh put our finger on it all the time
i think that that yearning that sense
that something's gone wrong
can be the beginning of of an awakening
of a political transformation of
something
um so in the long term i do have some
hope
even in even more than hope i have
optimism in the very
long term we went from hope to optimism
pretty good the book is the unbroken
thread the link is right down below
so arab i appreciate your time thank you
dave this is great
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell